good morning John is Wednesday August
9th I got home from the fair on Sunday
with a bunch of really great fare
footage and I was excited just to share
my fare footage with you and the
nerdfighters and because I'm a good
brother I always want your videos as
soon as I can so I click on your video
when I get home from the fair and I see
your video and you're all Hank walking
tall the world's largest board who can't
walk reminded me a little bit of
America's health care system and now I'm
all and then we have to figure out some
way to have some kind of impressive and
bizarre analogy between State Fair and
political issues so I can seem all cool
and smart like my brother hmm okay okay
I can do this I can do this I can do
this John
freestyle motorcross reminds me a lot of
the cap-and-trade system you have to
ramp it up real fast and then you'll get
to a certain point and you'll sort of
glide into a man ice soft landing in the
future and if you muscle it around just
the right way you can totally do like a
backflip he'll click oh no that didn't
work okay
American politics are totally like this
chicken they have a really short
attention span a fairly short life span
and at first when you're looking at them
they look kind of silly but then they
start to look really scary and also its
name is Hagrid it's name actually was
Haggard but that last part doesn't
really work okay this one's good this
llama is like the Democratic Party its
head is really big and really impressive
but its body is like thin and atrophied
and it can really seem to get anything
done on its own it's almost like the
body of the llama only thinks that it
needs to be a body every four years and
then once the body gets the head in
place it can completely ignore all of
its other responsibilities when really
its body needs to get involved and start
doing things because the freakin
Republican llama is going crazy with its
huge body that's tiny head okay here's
another one the situation in Iraq is
totally like this corn dog
because mmm
okay wait wait wait now I got a good one
I got a good one this one's gonna work
the cash for clunkers program is like
the demolition derby because well
actually I think that the demolition
derby is cash for clunkers like it is it
is the original cash for clunkers in
fact I'm starting to think that we
should just have a lot of demolition
derbies and kind of forget about this
cash
pokers idea you can give like a $4,500
prize to every person who wins the
demolition derby and instead of getting
one car off there or do you get like two
does it because they're all crashing
into each other and I guarantee you none
of those guards are ever gonna drive
again problem solved
okay that turned out all right John
thank you for challenging me to be
astute and to explain complicated issues
using the county fair and if I can have
a little bit of a serious response to
your healthcare video I would like to
say that the biggest analogy between the
healthcare system and the county fair is
that they're both trying to make money
off of us and you know I'm okay with the
fair making money I'm okay with the
carnie trying to get me to play the
carnival game cuz I can say that guy hey
guy how much does it cost and then he in
turn will say to me way more money than
it's worth and so I'll be like no I
don't think I will play your carnival
game but as soon as you tie money to a
doctor's responsibility to a patient
suddenly I imagine for doctors it's
difficult to separate making money from
making the best suggestions to your
patients and if a doctor says to me that
I need a procedure I'm not gonna ask him
how much it cost and I'm definitely not
gonna go around town and try and find a
better deal I'm just gonna do it because
we're supposed to be able to trust
doctors and now I think it's the real
problem with the health care system we
need to decouple the doctors
responsibility to the patient from the
amount of money that he or she makes
from that patient obviously this is an
extraordinarily complicated issue and
I'm not trying to say that doctors are
only out to make money off us but
there's a link in the sidebar to an
article from The New Yorker that goes
pretty deep into why Americans health
care budget is so massive it's a really
great article it's long but I swear it's
totally worth reading
I hope all nerdfighters read it and John
I definitely want to talk with you about
it later oh and there's no more there's
one more I got to put in here political
pundits are like fair rides because just
looking at them makes me want to puke